au bout de la passerelle flottante
une parenthèse enchantée
ici artistes et créateurs ont investi
les lieux comme cet orléanais et sa
fresque géante
personnellement ça fait deux ans que
j'ai pas exposer avec le co vide on a
trouvé d'autres manières de s'exprimer
est là aujourd'hui j'ai été capable de
faire une fresque de 100 mètres carrés
parce que j'avais cette frustration au
moins et j'avais envie de crier au monde
oui c'est possible de continuer à rêver
musique odeur une fresque qui appelle à
utiliser ses sens tout au long du
parcours des oeuvres bien différente
avec un thème commun les chemins de la
liberté
un message qui résonne plus que jamais
pour le créateur de l'événement
l'objectif c'est de continuer à faire la
fête dans ces moments un petit peu
trouble et puis continuer à se cultiver
évidemment moi j'organise la rencontre
entre des créateurs et des citoyens des
touristes et c'est ça l'objectif c'est
de continuer continuer à partager
questionnée c'est le but de la fête
déduit avec des visiteurs toujours plus
curieux cette réunion l'antre ce côté
nature et puis toute la symbolique là
qui a mené par l'art bain ça nous amène
une réflexion voilà on est dans une
réflexion champêtre les performances se
succèdent jusqu'à 23h une incitation à
la rêverie qui se termine le 16 août